so well I'd like to welcome you to the
2019 Wolfram technology conference this
is actually believe it or not the
thirtieth time that we have done this
this was the poster put that up this was
the poster put that up please
up I feel like that there so who is
there then by the way okay we've got at
least one two three okay terrific this
what that look this is what this looked
like then so I think it's an improvement
without the beard at least so well what
I'm gonna do today I'm gonna talk about
the state of our technology particularly
about what we've been doing over the
past year and what's coming in the near
future I warning there's probably gonna
be a pretty long talk cuz it's kind of
as I've been preparing this it's sort of
amazing how much stuff we're doing it's
more and more every year I might say
also this is the first time we're
live-streaming this talk so welcome to
the livestream audience and so they'll
get to see all the weird things that
happen in this extreme high wire act of
of demoing things we're doing well you
might think that after we've been around
for 33 years there will be pretty modest
progress yet year-to-year but it isn't
true in our case and partly that's
because we build technology for building
things and we use it and it really works
and it's also part of who we are as a
company we always like to be inventing
things even if they're quite often many
decades ahead of where the market is
well the core of everything that we do
is from language and
I'll be talking about lots of things to
do with working language here and as
I'll explain Wolfram language is showing
up in more and more places and we've
worked very hard in recent times and
over this past year to make wolfen
language more and more deployable well
one question is what what's sort of the
what's the significance what's that
what's the goal of often language what's
its kind of long-term significance and I
think I've understood that actually with
greater clarity over the past year that
I have over the preceding 30 years and
it's partly something that's been slowly
emerging as the language has been built
out more and more I think the way to
understand wolfin language it's the only
attempt to make a full scale
computational language it's different
from a programming language a
programming language is about you take
the things a computer can do and you
wrap stuff around that that lets people
tell the computer in detail what to do
computational language is a different
story a computational language is
something which is trying to describe
the world computationally you know the
big one of the big intellectual
achievements I think of the last century
is this computational paradigm for
thinking about the world and what we're
trying to do with our computational
language is to make use of that
computational paradigm to capture what's
going on in the world in a computational
way so what does that mean it means
we're trying to describe the world
computationally we're trying to describe
not just you know arrays and and values
and in computer memory we're trying to
describe cities and animals and things
about planets and spacecraft and things
about chemicals and so on we're trying
to describe all these kinds of things in
computational terms that's what it means
to have a full scale computational
language and I wrote the just something
I wrote recently about this it's some
the what what we want to be able to do
is to have a language in which we can
express computational thoughts if we get
to be able to think about things
computationally we want to
language where we can express what we're
thinking about and it's sort of an
analogy which I I find useful which is
you go back 400 years and you ask how do
people do math well they had to do math
by writing things down in natural
language those days mostly Latin and
they use words to describe math and
there were lots of things were pretty
hard to describe and figure out when you
used words to describe math but then
about 400 years ago people started
inventing mathematical notation it's
like plus signs equal signs stuff like
that and pretty soon it became much more
streamlined to talk about math and then
things like algebra got invented and
later calculus and so on and that's what
launched kind of what became the sort of
mathematical way of describing things
and the mathematical sciences led to
much of modern engineering and so on
well I view what we're trying to do with
whorfin language is sort of the same
kind of thing but for computation for
representing things computationally we
want essentially a notation in which we
can express computational thoughts and
what will that lead to well just as the
mathematical notation led to the
mathematical sciences so this can lead
to computational sciences and beyond in
general I've said for a long time that
for any field X there either is now or
will be a computational X and basically
what we're trying to do with wolfmann
language is to provide the language the
notation in which to express
computational X in the current times
when you read technical papers you'll
find that there's a bunch of English and
then there's a math equation well in the
future what I expect to see is there'll
be a bunch of text and then there'll be
a computational language piece of code
and what we've been trying to build is
that computational language that will
allow you to express things for
communication and what's really great
about computational language and way
beyond what happens with mathematical
language is computational language is
intended to be something that can be
communicated both human to human and
human to computer and so the idea of
language one of the big ideas is to have
a computational language which is
readable which is a which is a way of of
communicating computational ideas not
just to computers but also to other
humans and a way in fact beyond that a
way to help one crystallize one's own
thinking to help one kind of better
express oneself so that that's kind of
the the goal that the sort of big
picture version of what I see the
significance of evolving languages as as
being and I think the it has many
consequences I mean there are many
consequences in education for example
you know people think these days you
know people who go to college a lot of
them say I go to do computer science
I've got to study computer science but
actually what they really want to do is
to apply computation to something to do
computational X for some X and the
question is how do you get to
computational X well you might think all
you have to do computer science you have
to study data structures you have to
learn about how to do you know hashing
and this that and the other but actually
you don't because with our sort of full
scale computational language you get to
just use computation directly on its own
terms and kind of skip over all of that
kind of low-level computer science and
just get to computational X so I think
that has a lot of significance for the
kinds of ways that one thinks about kind
of getting to computational X in
education I think what we'll see in the
future is computational X is sort of
taking over all these different fields
exactly how that will play out at
universities I'm not sure well okay so
this is kind of a big picture of what
we're trying to do it's a big thing and
having people really understand this
idea of computational language and all
of the the implications of and the
content of a computational language big
challenge and and to kind of understand
what we've already done let alone what's
possible in the future and to challenge
that I would say we're only partway
we're only just at the beginning of of
achieving of that that challenge and so
we definitely need your help I mean
we're a fairly small company very much
oriented towards building things and
innovating
and we don't have as much bandwidth as
we might to explain things to the world
and that's where we need we need lots of
health you need to kind of take the
platform that we've built and and build
on it and of course there's lots of
opportunity in doing this because you
know there's create the computational X
for all X these are the early years of
most computational axes and they're the
it's the it's the early years that tend
to be the most fruitful usually if you
look at kind of the sort of the long
view of the history of science or
history of Technology you see these long
periods of fairly slow growth and then
there's some methodological advance and
suddenly there's a period of time when
there's rapid growth what we get with
computational X and with computational
language we have a new methodology now
this is the opportunity for rapid growth
in a lot of different areas and the
opportunity to be involved in it so in
addition to sort of building the the
basic fields there's also the
computational exposition of existing
fields and I'll talk some more about
later about our kind of expositions
project the kind of way of describing
things in computational terms with
computational essays and so on and also
with this whole sort of computational
language paradigm there's the
opportunity to create lots of new
generations of products and companies
and so on that that are enabled by this
and it's you know it's kind of fun
actually spreading spreading the word
about these kinds of things you know
I've given Oh more demos than i can
possibly imagine of our technology by
now and it's kind of its kind of
remarkable people are like saying oh my
gosh you can do that aha
it's kind of kind of neat when that
happens it's kind of like well actually
we've been able to do that for 20 years
you just weren't paying attention but um
it's some it's it's fun doing that and
it's something that Tim I encourage
people to get involved in ok well let's
let's talk a little bit more about sort
of the the here-and-now of what's going
on I'll give a whole bunch of previews
of things that we're doing and almost
everything I talked about will be just
just in more detail elsewhere at this
conference and I encourage you to find
the talk that actually discusses in
detail any particular thing that I'm
talking about so over the past year kind
of one of the bigger things for us was
April 16th version in 12 point O of
Wolfram language and Mathematica being
released and if you look at kind of
deser is kind of a long progression that
could be larger but that's so that's the
kind of just some version of what's
going on that's kind of the the growth
of number of functions as a function of
time number of functions is not the best
measure of everything because actually
the functions that we have today are
vastly more powerful than the functions
that we tended to have in earlier times
but it gives you some sense of sense of
the progress we're making
well since April 16th they've actually
been three major new releases in three
completely different areas and I'll talk
about all of them one is free water
management for developers and the
Wolfram Elgin system as a whole
another is Wolfram Alpha notebook
Edition and another is Wolfram notebook
publishing
I'll talk about all of those but first
of all let's talk about twelve point o
when twelve point oak came out in April
of this year it had been about a year
since version 11.3 but a huge amount was
added in that in that space of a year
there are about 278 completely new
functions and maybe a hundred areas with
lots of thousands of updates across
across the rest of the system um let's
see there's a word cloud of some of them
of some of what Tim what we had in
12-point oh um but we had this is kind
of a a rough summary of some of the
areas that were were covered in in the
version 12.04 kind of survey of some of
the things that were new in 12 window
and then we'll be talking about some
lots of other things this is
is a list of kind of all of the
functions that um were new or modified
into a window so it's a it's a pretty
long list and I'm just gonna scratch the
surface it's barely scratch the surface
boy that thumb is only half way down
here um okay
so let's take a look here all right well
first of all we added lots of math so
this is something we added it's complex
plotting there's a nice gamma function
in the complex plane we that's some 1:1
area I'm gonna I'm gonna go through
these things really quickly so another
another area we could call the calculus
one certainty dealing with numbers
uncertain numbers numbers with
plus/minus in them and there's a whole
kind of calculus of dealing with these
so for example when we add together two
numbers when uncertainty today the
uncertainties combined in a particular
way we can deal with all sorts of
different um deal with numbers with
uncertainty and all sorts of ways so
there's a plot with error bars and so on
convenient for dealing with experimental
data we're gradually extending the use
of around around the system so to speak
um I'm okay continuing with out of the
twelve boy dough story a lot of stuff
with polygons and polyhedra so there's a
nice some beveled dodecahedron that is
easy to make or we could say let's make
a random polyhedron with 50 faces here
go ahead and do that um so in addition
to computational geometry of that form
we did something that in a sense goes
back in history we kind of filled in a
Euclid and so what we did was to add the
primitives to be able to express
Euclid's style geometry so there are
things like this is a symbolically
represented triangle a symbolic
statement that there's a circle through
these things and this is now saying this
is a geometric scene find a random
instance of that find three random
instances of at that geometric scene
with those constraints satisfied try a
more complicated example here this is a
bigger thing that you might have sort of
taken out have you played
and now it's going to find an instance
of the that that set of geometric
constraints lots of things with geometry
this is just a particular the in radius
of a triangle there it's computed
something that we've actually been
steadily sort of filling in that the
2,000 year gap and trying to put all of
Euclid into computable form we finished
with books 1 2 3 4 6 and 13 and we're
steadily going through and making sure
that we can actually encode in
computable form all of these statements
in Euclidian geometry well okay so
another area so that's that sort of one
piece of the sort of story of formal
mathematics another thing is kind of
making things completely for melissa's
this is a pure axiom system and we can
take that pure accent system that was an
accident system I discovered about 20
years ago it's the simplest accent
system for boolean algebra and we could
go through and try and say given that
axiom system this is using our theorem
improving technology we can try to find
a proof of the in this case the
commutativity of nand and we can say
what's the network of theorems that
network of lemmas that represents that
proof um well what we've done now with
this function axiomatic theory is we're
dealing with sort of the the most formal
version of everything so those are some
traditional axioms for for boolean
algebra and you'll see if you if you've
been following a lot of details what
we've been doing the main innovation
here in a sense is that the formal
variable that's a backslash formal a it
used to have two dots which was really
ugly and confusing now it only has one
dot that doesn't seem like big progress
but it's important in the actual use of
this um and we can go and say you know
we now have this whole way of dealing
with completely formal systems so that's
for example that's the sort of the sort
of the erotism structure of boolean
algebra and we can say show us it all
sort of feeds into the groupings
function and shows us all the different
pasta
billion forms ok moving a completely
different direction it's another thing
we added in 1200 is n-body simulations
um so this is now a computation of an N
body problem with certain initial
conditions and so on and we can go ahead
which I didn't do here well that's a
shame
I need to I need to actually go through
and something I didn't didn't throw in a
metric plot 3d you know what I'm not
gonna do this because it's going to
involve too much typing but it would
make a nice picture of the three-body
problem if I type the line here to make
that work well actually you know what I
have to do this
I think what I want to do there let's
look at position of that with respect to
time time running from let's say zero to
four and see what happens here
well that wasn't encouraging was it so
let's see what I did wrong um I wanted
to do this
ah there we go okay that's showing for
the three bodies what the okay so let's
just say values of that and then what I
want to do this is not probably the most
efficient way to do it but I think this
will work
ah let me see I'll just pick up one of
these I think what I should be able to
do is to say thread that with respect to
T
[Music]
no I don't want to do that I want to do
through yeah okay now we've got a better
chance let's see what happens here and
let's say this and see how that works
no how could that not work what's going
wrong here let's see what happens here
okay I'm just going to yeah there we go
that's just fine
so that's a oh it's a 2d parametric plot
maybe ah okay we should have this was a
2d problem that I was solving okay I
could've that was the whole problem I
think so sorry about that
um okay this just this just proves it's
a real demo but uh there we go okay
that's more like it
it's a big maps that three-body problem
it's not surprising Newton can figure it
out and one day people will prove that
this is capable of universal computation
and that they that there are undecidable
questions and so on associated with it
but that's a different discussion well
in any case so let's go let's go to a
quite different topic here another
another area it's kind of numerical
mathematics is convex optimization so we
added kind of state of the art ability
to do convex optimization it's kind of
automatically handled by things like and
minimize when when when the problem
structure has the right form and but
it's able to do all sorts of powerful
things
another area nonlinear finite elements
this should be this should solve a this
is some kind of differential equation
PDE over a an annulus region um so we
can just show it that looks like there
we go solving it over that annulus um
let's redo the computation and now let's
let's make a plot
of that solution to the the PDE in that
region there it is um so that's the
that's the result so this is using on a
finite elements and then okay so that's
that's another kind of more
computational algorithmic type area
let's turn to two different kinds of
things let's talk about let's talk about
some more user interface new kinds of
things so this is some the function I
can eyes it's very convenient
I can eyes just I can eise's things and
if you um if you use that expression but
if you click that plus sign it'll tell
you okay it's this thing that was range
of ten but it's been ionized we can uh
nikon eyes it and look at and do that if
we just evaluate this with the ionized
in it it will be as if we had typed in
that whole list but we don't have to see
the whole list so as you're writing kind
of our computational language I can eyes
is a good way to kind of hide things
that you don't want to bother to show so
you know if I were typing some plot and
I start adding all sorts of all sorts of
complicated options you know I say
filling arrow ax ax e axis and I say you
know filling style arrow green or
something like this and I say I don't
want people to have to see that I just
go over here and I right-click and I
just say um I just say I can eyes that
and now it'll just show up like that
and now when I when you evaluate it
it'll go and use those options it's just
a convenient way to to organize
notebooks and things okay well we we
progressively add all sorts of
capabilities to the core language this
is a particular kind of functional
programming construct subset map that
was actually sort of inspired by work
we've been doing in quantum computing
but it's say it's a kind of a new type
of a new type of sort of to-to-to
function operator it's another area so
we've also been continuing in in version
12 we've
continued to work on a lot of machine
learning kinds of things so we've added
a number of new machine learning super
functions so one area for those is
anomaly detection so this is now finding
the anomalies in that list of numbers or
we could for example use the same
technology to synthesize missing data so
we've got a missing there and now we've
filled in a value for that missing by
using a model for the data and there's a
whole kind of calculus of missings that
we're that we're working on but sort of
the thing that this is all based on is
learn distribution so you give it a
bunch of data and learn the distribution
of that data and the data could be
pictures of dogs or it could be arrays
of numbers or whatever else and once you
have that distribution you can do a
number of kinds of statistical things
like you could say give me 20 random
variates from that distribution or
compute various kinds of rarer
probabilities which are kind of the
analogs of CDF's
for that distribution so this is a sort
of this learning distributions of
anything is kind of a core technology
for a machine learning that allows us to
do all sorts of interesting new things
so we've also have a neural net
repository which has been growing and
we've been adding sort of the latest
neural nets to that this is a particular
neuron that the BIRT neural net we're
downloading it from the repository okay
it's a 436 megabyte neural net sorry
take a moment to download but we'll be
able to then come now okay this is takes
a little while to download a half
gigabyte neural net um the good news is
that it's right there in the repository
and it's already been trained and all
sorts of other things I just wanted to
show you kind of a little bit about what
that looks like um so we'll have a sort
of symbolic representation of this
neural net when it is finally downloaded
come on
there okay here we go hopefully there we
go okay
so Wow this one only has some that was
boring it's it's a very flat you're on
that well that's no fun at all I got to
show you some other let me show you
something more interesting then um let's
try let's try this no on that okay so
what I wanted to show you is which I'm
also not oh I know I'm not able to see
this here this is okay what we'll we'll
come back to this when I start talking
about the future and things beyond
twelve point oh this isn't as exciting
in 1200 as it is in in in future
versions well okay let's um
let's take a look at some other things
that came in in twelve oh this is the
function image cases which tries to find
cases of kinds of things it knows about
it knows about around there about five
thousand picture about common picture
ball mounts in English and it knows
about all of those and maybe twice as
many of other kinds of things and so in
this particular picture it identified
these three regions that it thinks are
elephants and two regions that it thinks
as zebras so we can also do so that's
another thing is facial features so now
we can make a dataset there's a Star
Trek movie poster or something and
hopefully this will analyze the faces in
there and give us some some data on um
on these various faces um that was bad
um why did it do that complained for
some reason okay um all right so let's
keep going here another okay another
another kind of thing we're always
interested in sort of making more things
symbolic so another kind of thing is
symbolic color space so this is looking
at in the chromaticity in 3d
chromaticity diagram this is colors
within a distance point two of pink
another another
type of things I'm kind of rushing
through this I'm trying to show you
different kinds of things let me show
you things with audio that's another big
thing that happened in version 12 and
let's try this so we should get up a
little audio recorder here and I should
be able to talk let me see
hello computer let me talk to you and
see what you can understand and we
should get an audio object out and now I
should be able to say show me a
spectrogram of the audio that I just put
in and now let's see what happens I
should be able to try and speech
recognize that and this my ticular a
moment here okay pretty good um so so
that's another another thing that was in
1209 dove a standard feature of version
1200 the speech-to-text um here's
another thing this is this is doing
entity recognition in natural for
natural language processing you know
we've we've done a lot of work on
natural language understanding that's
how things like wolf malphur work taking
short utterances and completely
understanding those short utterances of
natural language and finding a symbolic
representation that we can then can
compute from a kind of more classic
problem in natural language processing
is to do things like take a big piece of
text like a book a media article or
something and then just say identify for
example all the in this case countries
that exist in that with here articles so
here what I did is I said show me all
the countries that in the Wikipedia
article about ocelots find all the cases
of countries in that Wikipedia article
so this is a cases of entity recognition
and we've built entity recognizes for
lots of different kinds of entities so
both ones that are kind of semantic and
ones that are more structural so we can
find all the adjectives or adverbs or
possessive modifiers all these kinds of
things
so okay so another completely different
area that we added in in version 12 is
computational chemistry so this is now
so we're trying to find sort of symbolic
computational representations of
everything in the world and so one of
the things we would like to be able to
do is to do that a molecular scale and
so this is now a symbolic representation
of MA in this particular case a very
familiar molecule
um h2o um and now we can make molecule
plot 3d out of that and around and so on
but this is a very industrial scale
effort so we can make a 3d plot of a
more complicated molecule were actually
a much more complicated molecule
willness perhaps we could take just a
sort of arbitrarily specified molecule
here and it will figure out using
essentially physics what a reasonable
shape for that molecule might be um and
we can we can then do computations on
these molecules so for example here's
big molecule and we could say okay this
in this particular case what am i doing
um something went wrong with the way
that I pasted this from okay let's try
doing let's try just taking that and
let's try putting that molecule and
there I don't know whether have any of
those kinds of bonds but you can see um
put that molecule there see whether it
has any of those okay so there it took
that molecule and it was highlighting
those particular carbon oxygen bonds
we can compute all kinds of other things
about molecules - all right different
area geo computation so here I'm taking
a a Geo list plot of a random geo
position of random points that are
constrained to be within the
computational geometry region that
corresponds to France
okay completely different kind of
geometric problem this is about labeling
plots and there's about dealing with
where do you put the labels so that they
work well on a particular kind of plot
we could do that term let's do another
one here this is some okay so here we're
oh this different thing again okay so
that that's this is another thing about
plots long requested the ability to make
multi-panel plots that have axes that
line up and so on um so that's that's
another thing in version 12 ok skipping
ahead here another thing we have many
kinds of entities that we know about in
whorfin language are hundreds of them
and in version 12 we documented all of
those so this is the page about
universities for example that describes
the different properties of universities
that we know about and all those kinds
of things so you can see even get some
sense of the of the depths of of
computational knowledge that exists and
we also made it so that we can expose
all that computational knowledge to
computations in the language so here
we're taking the entities element
entities and we're c'était saying take
the largest five elements by melting
point and there's the results well okay
so let's see the the another area is sum
has to do with dealing with data and so
for example one thing that we added with
these we actually had had a preliminary
version of this these things called
entity stores so this is an entity store
from our data repository this happens to
be a an entity store that represents the
the books in my personal library
together with sort of relations between
them so what you do is you get this
entity store you register the anti-d
store
and then given that there's a new type
of entity just like we can have entities
that are things like cities or or
chemical elements or whatever now we can
have SW library books so we could for
example pick 10 SW random 10 random SW
library books and each of these is an SW
library entity and we could ask
properties of it and so on I don't know
we could pick one of these and just say
give us a can do all the standard things
we would do with entities in the system
so now it's asking us give us a data set
of properties that we know about that
about that entity okay so another big
thing is what if you have some external
database perhaps their database that
your organization has had for decades
and you want to connect to it and do
computations with it so let's show an
example of that so one of the big things
added in version 12 was really
integrated support for relational
databases um so we can this is now
connecting to a small external database
but you can do this just as well for a
giant external database we can say treat
that database as an entity store then we
can say could say register the the
entities in there and so this particular
one is just a simple sample database
with various kinds of entities in it and
then we could say let's look and so in
terms of standard database thinking this
is tables and then these are the columns
in the table and so on and that we could
do computations we can kind of we have a
symbolic representation of all of the
kinds of things that we can do with a
relational database and we can map to
all the standard large-scale relational
database backends and so on and it works
very efficiently another completely
different area a different kind of non
relational database a graph store so we
can start dealing with things like
sparkles so this is a sparkle query and
that term is running against and what
that's running against it is oh it's
running against our internal knowledge
base so this is computing a sparkle
query relative to our
relative to all the knowledge that we
have in our knowledge base and hopefully
come on wake up um this might take well
okay there we go so this is saying that
this is asking a kind of a weird
question about some what relationship
does the US have to Mexico and the
answer is these are these are properties
that relate to the u.s. to Mexico in our
knowledge base so that was kind of a
weird type of query that we're able to
do with with sparkle in a graph database
okay another area that we added in
version 12 was the beginnings of our
full-scale compiler and so this is this
is the results of compiling a trivial
function x squared assuming that X is a
an integer 64 so we can compute the
result there now if we look at how did
this compiler work we can say export so
this is now computing a Fibonacci a
recursive function here assuming that
the variables are integer 64 x' now we
can do this is kind of looking under the
hood what's actually underneath there
and what's actually underneath there is
LLVM code that can be directly run
directly um compiled on on any machine
and run at the machine code level so
okay that's that's so that's a another
big big project okay so another thing we
we did in version 12 was added a lot of
capabilities to to deal with external
languages so we have here you know I can
type in something about some wedge means
I think X or and Python um so there's
that that's a python cell and we added
capabilities to do things like um be
able to splice in Wolfram language
inside the Python and then compute from
that or being able to deal with sort of
functions that are actually external
functions within Python being called and
actually running a more from language so
lot lots of kinds of things that are
lots of sort of
systems things that we added let me show
you oh just one random example let's say
we wanted to trace the network packets
on ports 80 and 443 when we did a URL
read too often comm this will now show
us all the network traffic that happened
while we were doing that interesting if
you're interested in computer security
kinds of things and so on
another thing is being able to interact
with the web browser so this is for
example going out to the web through by
puppeting a web browser and making an
image of the front page of Wolfram calm
um so again I'm trying to run through
fairly quickly some of the things we did
in in version 12.0 completely different
area interacting with the outside world
this is I'm dealing with
microcontrollers being able to take come
beyond compilation to standard machine
language this is compilation to two
microcontrollers like Arduino that can
run autonomously in devices and so on
and so here what I'm going to do
hopefully if this loads in is I'm going
to take this some something like this
filter and I'm going to to actually
produce microcontroller code that could
be run on autonomous microcontroller so
this is saying compile it for an Arduino
Uno and now we should get great we know
the app is not that that's probably not
our issue
um don't think it's a trap I think it's
some okay so anyway this is this is a
this is a piece of microcontroller code
that you could just download and run
autonomously okay well so many things
here I'm another area we worked on a lot
in 12 hours blockchain so this is
looking at the etherion blockchain is
asking for blockchain token data for the
CK token otherwise known as the crypto
kitty token and we could say let's let's
look at the complete aetherium
blockchain and let's do a computation
about let's make a word cloud that's
about all
that's kind of interesting actually
that's the the transfers on the etherion
blockchain and we're making a word cloud
of what the most popular kinds of tokens
that were transferred on the etherion
blockchain are so I guess the tether
system has won out in recent times okay
so that's some that was a very quick
tour of of kind of the work on version
12 which led to the release of version
12 in in April of this year actually
there's some other things I didn't
mention like the links to Bloomberg and
Reuters for financial data and so on but
okay what I want to talk about the big
thing I want to talk about next was the
things that have happened since April
16th and I said there are three new
product releases I'm going to talk about
them in kind of reverse order first
thing I'm going to talk about is
notebook publishing so if we go back to
to 1990 we are there we already had
notebooks you can see one up on the
screen there we'd been progressively
sort of refining and polishing this
notebook idea for the last 31 years
actually to be honest I think notebooks
just some of one of these simpler things
that we've invented over the years and
it's sort of remarkable that to me that
it took I don't over 25 27 years before
people really seemed to outside of our
community really seemed to get this idea
and that's kind of an indication of why
we need help
communicating why the world needs help
with the communication of some of the
other ideas that that we have that have
been part of language for often a long
time but okay here's the big new thing
the big new thing is really smooth
publishing of notebooks to the cloud so
the idea is you have a notebook you
created on the desktop I'm going to live
very dangerously here but we'll see what
happens and you can just take this
notebook so a big long complicated
notebook like this and we can just say
go to file menu and just say publish to
cloud okay let's see what happens here
so this is so it's not going to say we
can specify a name we could we can make
it public
okay might take a little walk is a big
crunchy notebook and what the
is now doing is it's um it's uploading
all that notebook content which in this
particular case will be many tens of
megabytes I suspect may be bigger than
that and it is creating a version of
this in the cloud and we'll see what it
manages to do okay it finally finally
finished there and um let's let's go
ahead and say okay view that in the
cloud actually you know what I want yeah
there we go so now this is going to get
a version of that notebook and we should
see all the different pieces of that
notebook showing up in the cloud and we
can take and once once it becomes active
here you'll see that little blue line
going across the top actually if I'd
waited just a bit longer it would have
been it would have loaded more quickly
because what's happening when you
actually publish to the cloud it's
making a cached version the server is
making a cached version of the notebook
so that it can have a fast initial load
and I probably didn't wait long enough
for a big notebook like this to let the
the the initial cache come in and it'll
take a little bit longer here to load in
the actual to load in the final final
interactive version but what we'll get
once once it's loaded in um and we just
want it's saying interactive loading you
know I should have waited a little bit
longer for for people who try
downloading this now okay so here it is
so it all exists here um in the cloud
and hopefully real soon now this will be
nice and interactive I don't go this
things should be waking up here and we
can it can start to rotate it and resize
it and so on so this is all now just
running in a web browser and now I can I
can just resize the thing and it'll
it'll rerun from the server and so on
okay so so this is kind of an important
thing because it means you can take any
content you have in a notebook you can
just immediately make a website out of
it and with all of the interactivity and
all the functionality that you were used
to on the desktop it's taken a long time
to get to the point where this can be
done but I think it's really important
for lots of purposes and I hope lots of
people will make use of this I think
that the
okay so let's sum um actually what I
should have done yeah okay so um let's
do the following so we could for example
let's take I just do I took well let's
just take the the URL here and let's
just say let's try doing this let's take
that URL let's make a QR code out of it
and then let's say let's take the QR
code and let's see what we can do with
this so we got that QR code there and
the whole point is that anybody you know
you can put up your phone and you should
be able to get to that notebook here I'm
gonna I'm gonna switch to this phone
here and I'm going to hopefully you'll
see that's the phone and now I want to
take a picture new and camera I don't
need to see what's new in the camera
okay there we go so now it says on the
phone opening in Safari and hopefully
okay and hopefully what will happen here
is that there we go there's the notebook
loading in so so now we can just read
this on our phone now what we can also
do is we can go to the phone here and we
can say and it's hard for me to read
this but but um yeah there we go
so there's a little button there at the
top that says make your own copy okay
maybe I'll show you this on the computer
rather than on the phone um so here if I
say make your own copy this is the so
this says make your own copy of this
notebook okay so what that's going to do
the published version will always stay
the same but you can so so anybody can
go I should explain one of the important
things is for anybody who has an account
publishing is free and once you
published a notebook anybody in the
world can go to that URL and can
interact with that notebook they can't
edit the notebook but they can interact
with it they can run manipulates they
can rotate 3d graphics they can open and
close cell groups all those kinds of
things
if they want to edit it and do
computations in the notebook then they
say make your own copy and then if there
are already users of the cloud of
something like wool from one then it'll
open inside there will from one account
if they're not they can create a
cloud-based account which is a free
account and they just have to give their
there and just have to log in and then
having done that they then get their own
version which they can then edit so and
they'll be able to do that in the cloud
so they can just run this in the cloud
and get ok there we go um I guess that
was a hard computation they can just run
that and do their own version of these
computations in the cloud and even in a
card basic account they can save the
results for up to 60 days for free so so
that's kind of the workflow is you can
create something you can you can
actually create your notebook if you
want directly in the cloud or you can
create it on the desktop then you
publish it then anybody in the world can
go there and interact with your notebook
it'll load in it'll do SEO like a
website it'll do all those kinds of good
things and then if people want to
actually do computations with a notebook
they say make their own copy and they're
often running in the cloud now they can
also take that notebook and they could
say that by the way this cloud app you
can honor on a phone you can be looking
at the notebook in the cloud app the
cloud app has some extra conveniences
for editing the notebook and so on but
you could do that if you wanted you're
just purely on a website on the web but
it's more convenient in the cloud app um
but any case then so the other option
that you have when you have one of these
notebooks is to say when you have a
published version of one of these
notebooks was the published version here
um I think it must be back um is some
yeah this is the published version is
you have a download button and if you
press the download button
you can download that notebook from the
cloud to the desktop and in the desktop
you can open it with the free Wolfram
notebook player which we've actually had
as a free player of notebooks for 30
years now so you can take this and then
the notebook player will allow you to do
the same kind of thing that you could do
with the published notebook on the cloud
but now you can do it on the desktop and
so things like manipulates will run
directly locally on your computer ok
there's one final additional thing that
that works which is that you can open
this publish notebook in your in the in
the notebook player that's another app
that exists for for iOS and maybe we can
try let's just try doing something ok so
let me let me try to explain what's
happening there let's say I say sendmail
let's say I stole from - test at Wolfram
calm and let's just send that string and
hopefully I will be able to to do this
ok so that should send mail ok and now
let's see what happens over here um so
now I'm gonna go to the phone and
hopefully there's a mail account set up
here let's see where's the mail account
they'll go no male what's uninspiring no
mail oh well I thought that would work
but um who knows the this is some ok if
that had worked yeah the the thing that
that what what Tim you know what I could
another no that won't work I need to and
I need to yeah that might work um what I
need to do is to get it so that I'm I'm
opening the this
I'm opening and let's say I sent myself
this notebook actually what I really
should have done is to send myself this
notebook as an attachment and when I
send it as an attachment it has been the
case in the past
oh you get a notebook as an attachment
what can you do with it well now you can
open it in the notebook player app and
it will be completely active and running
locally on your phone so you can run and
manipulate and you can actually run the
computations directly on your phone um
so that's uh that's a pretty neat thing
all right and so this is yeah that's oh
that's the regular player for the
computer and this is the player app okay
moving along so the thing to understand
here is you can publish you can take
notebooks all the notebook capabilities
that we built up over these last three
decades and you can publish them to the
cloud so people can just use them and
interact with them it's kind of like an
interactive version of the web it's a
way to provide rich interactive content
directly on the web so the way that the
sort of default publishing works you're
publishing something for the public but
you can set all kinds of permissions if
you want to even the basic publishing
dialog lets you do that
you can also instead of using our public
cloud to publish notebooks you can have
an enterprise private cloud and you can
do all these same kinds of publishing
things with a private cloud which is a
private version of our public cloud
infrastructure it's some so I mean one
of the things that I think is important
about notebook publishing is it helps
enable this idea of computational essays
as kind of a minha means of
communication I've kind of had this this
thing I've been talking about for a
while now where use Wolfram language to
enable sort of a new way to explain
things to people it's a mixture of text
and of natural language and
computational language you can read both
the natural language and the
computational language now in a sense
you say well it's so difficult to write
the computational language relative to
writing just words on a page type thing
but the fact is you get a huge benefit
from
from having computational language
because you write that little piece of
computational language and then the
computer goes and figures out what to do
from it so you get this beautiful
graphic and you've kind of got half your
document written for you so to speak so
this is so the trade-off is you have to
be more careful writing that
computational language because you
actually I really have to say what you
say what you mean precisely but then the
computer will will generate things for
you and I think computational essays are
kind of the future of lots of kinds of
communication whether it's people
writing data science reports or whether
it's students providing student work or
lots of other kinds of things well and
when you there are lots of tricks in
kind of reading that computational
language they're things like reverse
closed cells and icon ization and so on
that help to make a really readable
document in that computational language
one of the things that were in that
computational essay so one of the things
that sort of is made possible by not
book publishing and the idea of
computational essays is true
computational journals and you know I've
been thinking about computational
journals and computational publishing
for more than thirty years actually we
finally are at the point where the
technology exists we can really do this
and really have it work well and so I
think there's a lot of opportunity in
creating kind of the first really sort
of perfectly reproducible perfectly
complete computational journals and
actually at this conference we're going
to have a meet-up a bit later about
computational journals and we intend to
launch a computational journal and
probably other people will launch others
with our technology but I'm hoping to
kind of recruit our founding editorial
board and so on for our computational
journal here so something something in
the next couple of days well this whole
idea of computation back to publishing
there's lots of pieces to it even if
you're just putting out an image even if
you're just putting an image and a blog
post for example you can deploy it from
orphan language with a source link and
that means it will come out with a
little link-up
bottom and wrapped in HTML with a little
link at the bottom and that source going
can link back to a notebook that shows
how that image was produced and maybe
that notebook can link back to a an
entry and the data repository that shows
where some raw data came from it's a way
to really do sort of computation and
data backed publishing well okay once
you've published some once you've got a
notebook a published notebook what can
you do with it well you can just send
people to that web page that's fine but
maybe you want to embed that publish
notebook in something else
so you've you've been able to create
iframe embeddings it's easy to create
iframe embeddings one of the new things
is the notebook embedder
which is a library for embedding card
notebooks on websites so this allows you
to have sort of notebooks that are
really integrated into web pages and can
change size and can communicate in all
sorts of ways and deals nicely with SEO
on the website and things like this so
that's that's a new thing and in fact
now whenever you create a published
notebook it will give you the
opportunity to get this some embed code
to to do direct embedding on a webs on
web page like this coming soon is
embedding using the Oh embed standard
and that will make it easy to embed
publish notebooks in many content
management systems learning management
systems blogging platforms etc so that's
some that's another thing that some
that's in progress um all right and
actually I just wrote this last week a
blog post about the new world of note
book publishing and this has more
details about some of the things I've
just been talking about all right let's
move to the next topic so the next thing
I want to talk about I said there were
three new things since April 3 releases
since April 2nd one I want to talk about
is Wolfram Alpha notebook edition okay
so Wolfram Alpha notebook edition is is
is really a
kind of the whoops what is that I by
mistake our launch system model okay
that's fine and dandy all right that's
great it's lovely to see but not
relevant to what I was going to talk
about um what I wanted to do was to
launch water now for notebook condition
okay
the idea of Wolfe mouth and Oprah
condition is to take sort of the the
easy on ramp that Wolfram Alpha has
provided for people and merge it with
the power of Mathematica and so what's
what's great about Wolfram Alpha one of
the things that's great about Wolfram
Alpha is you don't have to explain
anything to people when they start using
it they just walk up to it and they just
start typing whatever they feel like and
it just works okay but when you use walk
now for it's kind of a drive-by one-shot
kind of thing you type in one question
you get some output and that's the end
of it okay but let's say that you wanted
to combine that with the kinds of things
you can do okay so let's do this let's
just type in some random expression here
and this is now Wolfram Alpha notebook
edition and what it should be doing is
using natural language input and then
generating the Wolfram language code and
producing producing output here and so
now I can build up this whole notebook
so I can I can go ahead and I can say
something like you know take that and
differentiate that and now it'll it'll
figure out how to compute that and we
can go on and say you know something
like plot it and the whole point here is
people don't have to know anything to be
able to interact with this but yet they
can build up computations in the same
kind of way that they've been able to
build up computations in Mathematica and
this is this product is aimed primarily
initially in this form it's aimed at the
kind of technical education particularly
mathematical education market and it's
intended to be something that any
student at the kind of junior college or
high school level or whatever can just
walk up to and start using without
knowing without having to learn anything
about syntax or anything like that now
of course they see the syntax here and
if they wanted to they could go ahead
and edit that and then they could make
their own version of the computation and
they'd be off and running doing things
using sort of full whorfin language but
the idea is to provide an easy on-ramp
for people to get to the power of what
has traditionally only been available in
Mathematica and you know technically
there are many things that had to be
solved this is a huge technology stack
that gets us to this point both the
whole technology stack of mathematical
morphing language and the wolfman alpha
technology stack and natural language
understanding and so on there are all
kinds of issues this is now a sort of
conversational interface where you can
go back and forth in natural language
you'll notice a lot of detailed things
like there's a input suggestion here
that says step by step solution so we
can press that and now we should get
okay it'll say show steps of that and
now we can say show all the steps we can
see that right in here and this is some
this is something intended to be we can
also let let's say we could say
something like come let's do this let's
say plot sign a X with a varying so what
that does um okay so this oh that wasn't
very exciting um I should have said come
on I didn't give it a chance sorry let's
try that um so that okay that's better
so now that just created a manipulate um
which we can then we can then work with
and now I mean it's the other thing you
can do with this is you can make this
into you can create a presentation here
so you can create you can make this not
um you can make this a presenter
notebook um and we can then go ahead and
start a presentation this is just the
sample one um and and now we've got
something which is kind of like
PowerPoint except that we can actually
interact with it here so
so that's some hopes and presentation
good um so okay another thing you can do
you can go ahead and share these
notebooks that you've created and
welcome off a notebook edition you can
share them with students and so on
you can send kind of partially filled
out ones that can be used for exercises
and so on all sorts of things you can do
now another thing I'm not sure I can
show you let me figure out how to show
this to you let me show you another
thing you can do is you can go and take
demonstrations I wonder if I can do this
directly let's see um let's take a
demonstration here let's take a random
control theory demonstration one of
these will be um let's say copy to
clipboard okay now I can take this over
to notebook Edition here and I should be
able to just paste that this works
correctly I should be able I just picked
a random demonstration so I don't know
you should be able to just just paste
this in and start okay this happens to
be a little bit slow but but start
running it here so this is a way to
produce content a very convenient way to
produce content and integrate it with
notebook addition okay so um by the way
in case you're wondering in in the next
version in 12.1 even Mathematica will
have the capability to make a Wolfram
Alpha mode
notebook which works this way and by
default has natural language input in
addition to the usual orphan language
input notebooks so this pattern of using
natural languages input will become more
common this is kind of our first
prototype of doing this kind of thing
but you'll see other uses of that term
of that type of technology in the future
so that's what from alpha notebook
Edition okay so a third sort of new
release of the last few months is
Wolfram engine and Wolfram engine is
kind of the the core computational
engine that implements the Wolfram
language and the idea
and one thing that we've done now is to
make sort of a big step is to make a
free wolf mention for developers so the
idea is anybody can just go and press
this button and download Wolfram engine
sign-in and they're often running and
able to develop things with Wolfram
language and kind of the kind of the
deal is it's free so long as you're just
developing software if what you're doing
is producing an end product like you're
producing a data science report then
that's something that is that that's
something you have to get a license for
but if you're producing if your idea is
to produce software then when you take
that software into production then you
get a license to do that but during the
development phase you can do whatever
you want with free wolfram engine for
developers so that's kind of the the
idea there and it's Wolff mention it's
really the thing that's intended for
serious deployment and to sort of
explain that I'm going to have to go a
little bit down the software engineering
rabbit hole here so for those who are
not too into that I apologize but I
think it will be of interest to some
people here so okay so you have a wolf
Mangin it's this it's this thing that is
interpreting Wolfram language how do you
actually talk to it what do you do with
it well so one one approach is to use
Wolfram script Wolfram script is a
command line interaction with with
Wolfen language and there are a variety
of ways to use that in a sense you know
I could just go and I could just start
up a terminal here and I could say um
this is you know what's what's really
terrible about this is this is just like
when that first Mathematica conference
we could do just the same kind of thing
but anyway I say Wolfram script here and
I've got a command-line interface I used
to type you know 1989 to the power 1989
and he used to be really slow but now it
isn't and but anyway one one interaction
with with the Wolfram engine is just
that command-line interface but Wolfram
script allows other kinds of
interactions like running screen
it can have a you can have a something
where you have a function defined on the
command line let me show you something
else about Wolfram scope so I could say
I'm let me exit this thing here um
and let me say welcome script down here
and then let me just say - code and then
I say like 10 factorial okay
and it will then run that we'll just run
that Wolfram script run the code 10
factorial okay just to make it a little
bit more interesting I could say run
that code 10 factorial but run it -
cloud and that means what it's going to
do is it's going to run Wolfram script
not against the local wolf mention that
I have installed but against a wall from
engine in the cloud
um and I have to log in here and it will
then run the same thing and give that
result so you could do that whether you
have the Wolfram engine installed
locally on your machine the exact same
plumbing or work with the Wolfram engine
running in the cloud so you can you can
run when you're running it locally you
can have a persistent version of the
Wolfram engine that's always running in
the background as a WS TP server that is
being connected to every time it's not
restarting its being connected to every
time you actually want to do a
computation and that's something that
can be sort of automatically discovered
in our network and just provides links
to kernels on demand okay well you can
also do something else which is to
interact with the Wolfram engine from
other languages and so for instance um a
big new thing is the Wolfram client
library for python and there's a very
clean way to interact with Wolfram
language you can kind of use Wolfram
language syntax kind of inside Python so
let's see if we can let's see if we can
do something really contorted let's try
and run let's try and run in a python
cell so this works now I'm running
Python initialization
in a python cell in a walking notebook
let's try it let's try this again okay
so let's try now evaluating a Wolfram
language function in all right let's try
that so that what that okay so what that
did was it ran using a Wolfram engine
using wolfin kernel it it ran WLX per of
range of five a piece of Wolfram
language code inside Python it then got
the results back to Wolfram language and
returned a list there so that's some so
you can do you can do much more
elaborate versions of the same thing but
that basically gives the indication of
what happens there um and we also have
from version for Java we've also had a
versions for C and C++ and so on which
would actually have been nearly 30 years
in the form of W STP for calling warm
engine from within those other languages
and you can connect if you really want
to you can connect inside something like
Jupiter and you can connect just like
you can now use Wolfram notebooks to
connect to other languages you can use
to pedir notebooks to connect to of
mentions um you can let's see so that's
so that's the sort of the story of
connecting to or from engine from an
external language or an external system
like that
um so wolf mentions could exist locally
on on a local machine a desktop or a
server locally they can also exist
inside clouds so the the the main
Wolfram public cloud or an enterprise
private cloud inside it deep down are a
bunch of Wolfram engines that are
running and so it's very easy to deploy
an API to create an API that can be
deployed in our public cloud that's just
a cloud deploy of an API function to
make an API that will run in our public
cloud but there's other ways to deploy
API so for example here's an example of
something that way you can kind of see
you or from engine in action because
this is a direct
this is a Wolfram Web engine for Python
so what that is is a this this is a
little head spinning and I'm going to
try and summarize what's happening that
it's kind of complicated when you start
inserting Wolf's mentions all over the
kind of computational infrastructure of
modern software engineering um
so in this case this is a Wolfram engine
that can be correct directly connected
using Python to a web server and can you
kind of get to see every detail of that
and it's kind of a do-it-yourself kit
for doing those kinds of things so you
know the basic message is you can
integrate Wolfe mentioned into your
infrastructure and run Wolfram language
in a sort of full production mode and
and kind of the in terms of how this
works from a licensing point of view the
concept of you is your licensing wolfram
engines all of this middleware and
plumbing is really just sort of stuff
that you can download from github or you
can get from us or whatever else the
plumbing is not the point the point is
the Wolfram engines inside it well in
fact kind of reflecting this some I
should say that there are many different
versions of how you license warm engines
whether it's for local and individual
enterprise systems the distribution with
software for distribution with hardware
for deployment in cloud computing
platforms etc etc so each one of these
has many sub cases of you know you want
to deploy a wolf mansion in a piece of
hardware and so on there's there's ways
to do that so kind of recognizing this
sort of new world of middleware for
dealing with with Wolfman language
there's a there's actually a section on
the main documentation page connectors
libraries and middleware and you'll see
all sorts of things and there'll be an
increasing number of these kinds of
middleware connectors that are part of
inserting Wolfram language into the
infrastructure and we look forward to
lots of community development around
these things as well okay so you can
also when you're when you want to use a
Wolfman gene you're doing programming
for off mansion you can use the notebook
interface to do that programming or you
can
an IDE a traditional sort of software
engineering IDE and so there let's take
a look at that on this we can see there
are a variety of IDs for which we have
support and which are and which for
which other people have provided good
support for from language here's a
particular world of Arts one done by a
member of our community um this is for
IntelliJ and there so you can use
Wolfram language with backing running
wolfin language in a welcome engine
using an IDE to create the code and to
manage what you're doing so okay it's
some the as I said there are these three
new releases the third big one is well
from engine and it's kind of this is all
part of the story of sort of how to get
Wolfram language to thrive as well as
possible in the world and you know it's
sort of interesting since Mathematica
first came out 31 years ago there's been
arguably more innovation in licensing
models for four things than there has
been in for example programming
languages as such and so one of the
things that we've been interested in is
kind of how do we how do we sort of take
advantage of and make use of those
innovations in licensing that have that
have have emerged and you know one thing
people say oh why don't you make
everything open-source I don't think
that's the the solution I don't think
that there's actually a good good post
that John McLean wrote actually about
why why our technology isn't open-source
and kind of interesting to trace through
kind of what what we've been able to do
over the last 30 years and the kind of
path of innovation that we've been able
to follow and why kind of the that sort
of been uniquely made possible by the
particular model that we've had of a
sort of private company that's able to
concentrate on actually producing
innovative technology and really making
it work and we're kind of the customers
of our tech
are actually the people who are paying
for the developments of the technology
rather than some sort of third party
thing and it's it's sort of a it's sort
of frustrating to people like me that
sort of enterprise software and sort of
software selling kind of got a bad name
because a lot of enterprise software
companies have had this kind of spiral
of dramatically increasing prices over
the years which we have not done and in
fact and we've also tried very hard to
maintain compatibility and I'm always
pleased you know I was just recently
actually using a bunch of notebooks that
I created around 1998 and they basically
just worked which was very encouraging
um but you know I think sort of the a
lot of kind of what's happened in
enthusiasm for open source kind of
reaction to the you serious tactics of
some enterprise software companies but
it's also becoming clear there's a lot
of mess associated with you know what do
you do when you have something that's
free and then how do you actually pay
for its development and there's a lot of
kind of bait and switch mechanisms that
developer as a result of that we have
wanted to build something that is really
sustainable and that really allows us to
continue doing innovation for for the
long-term future but but there are still
things to learn from what's happened
around open source and I think free wolf
Mangin represents one sort of slice of
things that can be learnt from that as
does our notebook publishing mechanism
and of course there are many things that
we do that are probably more open than
anybody like for example one one thing
that I've been doing a lot some is live
streaming our internal design review
meetings and I I I think maybe some
people here have have watched some of
these it's great for us because we get
kind of instant feedback from a lot of
users and other people about the things
we're doing I also think the archive
makes for a pretty interesting
collection of kind of software
engineering kind of practices
but you know we've been kind of opening
up the process of how how to design
Wolfram language systems so another
thing that we've done that's kind of an
opening process is to have them I have
to register for this um this is for
right now for our pre-release
participants in our pre-release program
we have an open bug tracker and that
will be extended to other people I think
in the future and actually we have been
live-streaming we just started we just
did our first live streamed bugs review
reviewing the bugs that have been
reported and and pushed by by users who
are using this open bug tracking system
and so we're talking about kind of what
we're doing about these bugs and trying
to understand how they should be
prioritized and so on so another thing
that some i've been thinking about a
bunch is sort of how to ensure the
really long-term vitality of Wolfram
language you know we're at 31 years and
Counting so not so bad so far that's
more than half the total history of all
programming languages basically but I've
been interested in trying to understand
how to create something like a wolf and
language foundation that will be able to
ensure that whatever happens the Wolfram
language will maintain its availability
and vitality to people and well it's um
I think the the thing that um so I'm
hoping perhaps some people here will be
able to get involved and give commentary
about what we could do for a for that
long-term to ensure the long-term
vitality of our language okay so talking
about kind of the overall picture of
wolf and language there's sort of what
is the there's this notion that we have
of hyper architecture its kind of the
sort of you know
notion of cloud and desktop and all
these different deployment mechanisms on
all these different pieces that are
unified to provide this kind of hyper
architecture the entry points into this
hyper architecture is our product will
from one which is our first hybrid cloud
desktop product and but the idea of our
hyper architecture is that everything is
modular it's like extending the idea of
language design to the design of a whole
system so that you can add modular
pieces for different kinds of
deployments and so on and you'll see
more and more of the hyper architecture
over the next year and beyond
ok well so that's a little bit of the
sketch of kind of the deployability
of Wolfram language and and so on I
think let me talk about some talk about
some some other things here I'm I'm a
few other things we're doing and then
I'm going to talk about version 12.1 and
some of the the things that are coming
in the near future and perhaps a few
surprises
ok so continuing here so Wolfram Alpha
was 10 this year 10 years old
oops that's a wolf now for in Japanese
ok um there's a Japanese version of
Wolfram Alpha as we can see and the
which I can't use um the you know what I
must have set this to Japanese I think
that's what happens here there I can't
read that okay there we go in English ok
so one of the things that happened in
more from Alpha in the last few months
is that it it has a new web front-end
that makes it much faster and also makes
it responsive so so that it can so we
now have kind of the same codebase
running on mobile as on desktop and
that's a that's a nice kind of feature
there so wolf malphur is now providing
computational knowledge for both Syria
and Alexa
more intelligent assistants will be
coming on board soon there's lots and
lots of new content and WolframAlpha
which I will not talk about here i as i
as i just showed there's a japanese
version that exists there's also a
spanish version which I will not use I
won't press translate here I will spoil
e it's probably effect um but there's
the Spanish version of Woolf Martha
that's coming soon there's so that's
that's the story in Woolf malphur and
Wolfram cloud a lot of work has been
done on Wolfram cloud um
the it's the cloud is a very difficult
project it's some been it's a very
complicated software engineering
environment and distributed a lot of
very distributed system but we are we're
managing to for example take all of the
things that we've done in the very
polished notebook interface that we have
and we're making that stuff will work in
the cloud and the notebook publishing
that we've been doing is an example of
that
achieving sort of parity with the
desktop well you can see if you go to
the the sidebar he will see all kinds of
useful things like oh there's the we
call that thing the butler wolf and this
is just a first five minutes of things
for people to try in the cloud again
it's just a cloud notebook um the there
are other things here you can say you
know those are some things to try you
can encourage people to try these out
this is kind of a you know just things
you can run in the cloud to see what
term what what language can do um well
there are all kinds of new things that
exist in in the cloud this is as I said
this is just a card notebook so I can I
can do all the standard things with it
here's an example something that exists
now in the cloud this is you type
ah okay the okay I think it must be
coming soon oh I know what I'm doing
well
um the this there's some new things like
the ability to type two-dimensional
input by typing just input form and then
saying make this two-dimensional to
enter that as input in in the cloud and
that's useful for some educational
applications that cloud particularly um
also enterprise private cloud private
version of our infrastructure this has
been advancing greatly one of the
challenges has been to make it possible
to get all the things that we're doing
in the public cloud and flow them into
the enterprise private cloud efficiently
we're now finally getting to the point
we hope real soon now being able to do
simultaneous releases of the public
cloud in the enterprise private cloud
and a new thing that just happened in
private cloud is the ability to do
Custer ring of service for the private
cloud so to make more robust
infrastructure for the private cloud
just to give you a sense of what's
involved in a prior if you get a private
cloud what do you actually do here's the
configuration notebook of the private
cloud you get to kind of specify all
these different things about the web
subdomains the mail settings the account
settings database administration all
these kinds of things that's how you set
up a private cloud that can be as as
rich as possible in your in your
infrastructure so there lots of use
cases for the private cloud you can have
notebooks in the private cloud you can
serve API is in the private cloud you
can make it the backend for some
connector from Python or Java or
something
here's another thing you can do in the
private cloud you can have a a cloud
connector for Excel so there's a new
product this is something where you can
back your Excel spreadsheets with
Wolfram language api's so you can do you
can compute in you can select your data
in Excel and you can just get the
computation done in in a private cloud
so they're starting to be all sorts of
serious private clouds in the
infrastructure of the world just as
there are many enterprise wolf Malthus
in the infrastructure of the world so to
speak um I have to say it's getting kind
of complicated all these different ways
to deploy wool from engine as a server
and let me just try and summarize some
of these to just remind you about what
happens so this is so the idea is you've
got Wolfram language you've got Wolfram
engines you're trying to use the Wolfram
engine as a server how do you actually
communicate with that server well you
can use the public cloud then that gives
you notebooks that gives you ap eyes but
it's operating the public infrastructure
you can go to the enterprise private
cloud so that's a basically a copy of
the public cloud but operating in your
private environment it could be running
on a AWS or a zoo or something or it
could be running in your own your own
data center okay so that's next level
the next level is a new product which
isn't out yet but will be coming soon is
Wolfram Application Server and I'm sorry
this is complicated all these different
levels but they're all important and
they're people who really care about
each one of these levels so wolfmann
application server is an API serving
version of Wolfram engine so it's
optimized to serve API is it can let you
deploy forms and things like that and it
runs it doesn't do authentication of
users it it doesn't deal with any of
those kinds of things but it runs it's
it's deployed in the kubernetes
container or docker container and it I
should have explained that the Wolfram
Enterprise pirate card is a virtual
machine is a separate virtual machine
the idea of the application server is to
minimize API call overhead and it's
about three times faster to call a
minimal API than it is in an enterprise
private cloud because it isn't doing any
of those authentication things or other
kinds of things that take resources in a
full private cloud so this kind of the
optimized I just want an API it's inside
my infrastructure I'm going to deal with
how the thing is custard and so on but
this is some this is the sort of pure
API server so you go further
down I mentioned the Wolfram web engine
for Python which is more of us kind of
do-it-yourself kit where you're
connecting the Wolfram engine directly
to a Python web server there's even a
even lower level version lightweight web
evaluator where it's actually running in
the same sort of process space as your
as your interactive session and then
there's also the pure W STP server
evaluator which is essentially a
continuous server for wolfram engines
running with respect to local local
things like Wolfram script so sorry it's
kind of complicated but all of these
different levels are really a use are
really useful and the I mean the big
theme is just get Wolfram engine and
Wolfram language to sort of fit as well
as possible into the whole fabric of
modern computing make Wolfram language
ubiquitous you know I have to say that
my kind of analogy for this is if you
look at the history of computing there's
a question of what can you what can you
take for granted will you just walk up
to your computer back in the early days
of computing there was just machine code
then you could start taking for granted
you know the low-level languages like
Fortran and COBOL and things like that
then maybe the computer actually had an
operating system then later on it had a
networking user interface things like
this well the goal is to have it have
computational intelligence as something
you can take for granted to be able to
just walk up to the Machine and be
running Wolfram language and be able to
have the machine have sort of the
computational knowledge of the world
built right into it and that will be the
future and we're just working slowly
towards it and in fact um you know
there's already Wolfman language sort of
implicit in a lot of systems like
intelligence assistants and so on are
coming the next year they actually much
more visible instance of Wolfram
language that will be very widely
deployed it's the so so this is kind of
the vision is inject computational
intelligence everywhere through Wolfram
language make Wolfram language a you bet
just feature of the kind of computing
landscape just as operating systems and
user interfaces are ubiquitous feature
of the computing landscape well things
like the cloud are very easy to
integrate into lots of kinds of
computing notebook publishing is one
direction obviously whorfin engine is is
intended to be easier to integrate into
the computing world another direction
for integrating or from language is
being able to compute with things that
are stored elsewhere so one of the one
of the cases for that is to be able to
have for example things stored in Google
Drive and be able to use Wolfram cloud
with resources that are stored in the in
Google Drive and that's relevant to
fusing things like Chromebooks for
example that allows you to run the
things like Mathematica online directly
on Chromebooks so that's a or
programming lab or wolf enough a
notebook Edition I should have mentioned
by the way the the version of Wolfram
Alpha of a notebook Edition that I
showed you that is currently available
is for the desktop there will also be a
version of Wolfram Alpha notebook
edition that runs purely in the cloud
and that will be running well off things
like Chromebooks and so on ok another
place you can have notebooks is in
something like github and then in github
there's a way of having notebooks so
that there's kind of a badge that you
create so here's a github repository and
this little badge that says view or from
notebook versions of this repository and
there are the notebooks that you can now
access from inside github and actually
that integration will get closer in the
future so as we develop Wolfram language
there end up being all sorts of new
patterns for how we deploy things so one
new pattern is our resource system which
enables our various repositories and so
those are for example the the data
repository which came out a couple years
ago which is a place to put sort of
somewhat curated data to make it
immediately computable and
also something that has also been out
for about a year or so is the neural net
repository which has been progressively
growing that stores neural nets and and
each time we can we can use the neuron
that by by just clicking here and we go
in here and we just copy that and now
it'll download the neural Nets it's
another huge one and then we can use it
within our Wolfram language session in
the cloud you don't have to do that
downloading because it's already right
there in the cloud but that's that's the
idea so um an existing repository is the
demonstrations project a great example
of community contribution now twelve
thousand or so demonstrations that have
been contributed by many of you and many
others and that's that's great I showed
you before the the capability now to
just copy paste from the demonstrations
project the demonstrations project is
it's going to be programmatic too so for
example I can go and say something like
demonstration project is actually just a
piece of the resource system so this is
now a you can just take that's resource
data that particular demonstration like
this is the wonder of symbolic systems
that you can just have this thing that
is just a symbolic expression that is
the actual demonstration that comes from
the demonstrations project and it's now
immediately available inside your
notebook so on other things which are
sort of in the repository there's the
Wolfram challenges website where
continues to be popular there's a
challenge being done every second and
lots of different kinds of Wolfram
language Wolfram language questions that
you can that you can answer directly in
the cloud and and be checked and so on
44% of submissions are correct when they
are supposed submitted okay so a new
thing that we just came out in the world
of repositories is
the function repository so this is
intended to be something that um let's
take a look
repository tools about that we'll have
it's a good example recent resource
functions about that okay so the idea
here is that you have a you are adding a
function to Wolfram language in such a
way that anybody can use it
they just paste it in there and then
they can run it and so this particular
function seemed to told us some recent
resources that were added to the
function repository but there are lots
of lots of different kinds of functions
here there are just about let's see I
think it's around the 908 published
functions apparently with 49 still in
the queue as of today actually the has
just been a big function repository
function sprint leading up to this
conference and we're going to have a
prize for the winner of the function
sprint which will be announced on on
Thursday at noon I should just say
something about the function repository
why is the function repository possible
it's really a consequence of the way the
Wolfram language works it's something
that um you know when if you want to
have let's say something related to
image processing you want to have a a
function that does something with images
well if this was going to be a library
in some low-level language you would
have to have in addition to the actual
you know prize function that you want to
implement you would also have to have
you know 50 supporting functions that do
things like load images from this format
and convert things than this than that
in the other way but the point is
because the Wolfram language has this
symbolic representation that and it is a
full scale computational language when
you want to add that one prize new
function you just have to add the one
prize new function you don't have to add
all of that supporting material and so
that means that these that that's what
makes the function repository
simple and useful that single functions
at a time can be really powerful you
don't have to add whole libraries with
all kinds of tentacles that that twist
themselves up and get confused with
other libraries and so on you're just
adding one prize function at a time so
to seek and there are lot of great
functions actually that um that now
exist in the function repository and
kind of the the concept here is it's
much more lightweight to put something
in the function of posit or e than to
put something in the main language and
it's something we've seen and Wolff now
for in other places that will will put
something in to off now for and then
we'll say let's promote it to being part
of Wolfram language and it's a huge
amount of extra work to get something to
the point where it's really robust
enough to be part of our long-term
language um but we can get some
functionality that's really useful to
people in there much more quickly and
that's what is enabled by the function
repository and you can function
repository is engaged with our automated
testing system so it can guarantee that
things keep working and so on let me
just show you what it what's involved in
putting a function into the function of
depository so you just go file new and
then you go repository item and then you
pick function repository item and let's
make a little bigger here and this is
now we're off and running this is some
this is so I'm going to send enter a
function so let's say it's called
keynote function let's just called a
keynote um and let's say make a keynote
um and let's let's give a definition
say keynote of that is let's say I don't
know random random word a hundred or
something okay um and now so that's our
definition there then the usage we can
say keynote of let's do this explanation
okay so let's let's now say well let's
say okay here's an example we can put in
some examples down here actually if we
want to be a little fancier we can you
can let's say we want to add details and
options here so let's make for example
let's open up the tools here and we'll
get something
we can say make a table so let's say a
three-column table and let's say this is
an option I don't know max items goes to
default is 5
max items or something etc etc so we can
we can do all of those kinds of things
and we can we can really build high
quality documentation for our functions
ok so let's say now we want to let's
let's say we want to check what we've
done ok so we press the check button and
it's gonna say found one potential issue
in one suggestion okay so it says empty
rows should probably be removed from
tables and I think it had a suggestion
as well let's see what it's that was
that was Ono author information given so
it's complaining about that so the idea
is you I should have made some other
mistake here but but the idea is you
fill out this sum this function you fill
out this entry to the function
repository it's very fast to do that
then the system will prompt you for
things that don't follow the style
guidelines you get to correct those it
will often make suggestions for how to
make the corrections and then when
you're ready well for example you can
say preview it you can say preview and
I'd say preview on let's say preview on
the cloud so now um let's do that whoops
I said here that's actually let's just
go ahead and deploy publicly in the
cloud it's not gonna be it's gonna be a
little weird here but um we can go ahead
and deploy this and now we will get a
frontal it's not a very good one but we
can get a function repository shingle so
to speak in the cloud this is a private
this is a a publicly accessible but not
in the function repository shingle for a
function ok so if I had filled it out
properly
I could have copy/paste Watchi I can do
it I could do that I can just say
keynote of that actually if I did the
copy/paste correctly it would pull in
the this whole URL up here and it would
allow me to call this function from any
piece of Wolfram language code but so so
this is the this is so anybody at any
time you can
publish a function for other people to
use it won't be part of the public
repository it will just be something
that is publicly published to the cloud
for other people to use and they'll have
to refer to it by its specific URL now
you can then submit it to our public
repository and we try to to process
these submissions quickly
a few days type time skill we hope to to
then publish these things so that they
are available and advertised in the
public repository so it's going to be an
interesting process but by the way
there's versioning and things in the
public repository and that deals with if
you've used a version of something from
the public repository and then a new
version comes out it gives you an option
to download that etc etc etc um so it's
gonna be interesting dynamic because
there a lot of really good things that
people are putting into the function
apposite ori over time who will probably
promote some of these things to the main
language there'll be a bunch more work
as I mentioned to sort of robusta Phi
there and and really clean the design
for the ages so to speak for the
language but what's in the function
repository is a good fast way to get to
a lot of that functionality I might
mention that the functions and the
function repository they can use
external libraries - they can use you
know you can power peas Python code in
there or something like that on the
desktop that's pretty easy to deal with
in the cloud there's a complicated
sandboxing issue because when you're
running arbitrary external code you have
to have to make sure that that's safe
but we're gradually dealing with that
and I think they're probably already
used some examples of them of sort of
external code that exists in oh this was
I didn't mention this this was just the
the picture for the function sprint um
the eye
mentioned by the way that that one of
the sources for functions and the
function repository are things that
existed within welcome alpha they're
kind of too specific to be built-in
functions like show the resistor color
codes for something or um you know give
me the sunspots in space weather for a
particular period those kinds of things
or even even this is one that could
perhaps be generalized this is you know
generates some 3d Riemann surface plot
again these are all things that are
coming now from the function repository
they happen to be sourced from the wolf
alpha codebase or here's another one
actually this is a oops that's still
running there I don't know what I take
takes so long oh there we go it's quite
beautiful but Tim took a little while to
generate um and this is another one this
is 3d plot of the solar system with them
various planets and so on and it
computed for the current time but I was
going to show you the gonna show you
kind of what happened um but anyway
these are things that are function
repository functions that are a little
bit too specific to be to be part of the
language at this point here's an example
from importing the yamo specification
using a using external Python code and
that's an example of kind of wrapping an
external language code I mean the big
advantage that you get is once you've
wrapped it in Morphin language code
you've built something that has kind of
unified design and can communicate it's
sort of guaranteed to be able to
communicate with all the other parts of
the system so that's some so that that's
the that's what we can do there
okay so we've learnt a lot from building
out the function repository one of the
things that's coming real soon
is the is C is being able to hold on one
second here
see what we can do here why am I not
seeing what I thought I would see there
one second let go okay so um we can that
was that little sleight of hand had to
do with the fact that I'm now running
version 12.1 here um so this is now
there should be a data repository so
this is now a new bed repository one of
its problems has been it's rather hard
to it was too heavy weight to be able to
upload data to the data repository so
using the ideas the things we've learnt
from the function repository we've now
made it really easy to upload data to
the data repository so that's a that's
another new thing that's just coming
okay so in the future we're going to
have a padlet repository that can deal
not just with individual functions but
with full packets one of the things
that's happening right now is defining
kind of sort of making a fully
documented version of how Pat let's work
the the difference between a padlet and
a function I said you know these
individual prized functions work really
well but sometimes you want a whole
environment unfurled inside your Wolfram
language session you know with palettes
and all kinds and styles and all kinds
of other things that's something you can
package up in a packet and the packet
repository will be a much more that kind
of forking and source control and all
those kinds of things and unfurling full
collections of assets okay there are
other repositories coming another
example of a repository that is coming
is the actually already available on
already available on the web is the
formula repository so this is a
repository of know what you can have
here let's see
allama tree relation for tree trunk and
diameter okay so this is a this is just
a way of computing in the cloud these
formulas and you'll be able to enter
your own formulas and then access them
also from within the language it's a
convenient packaging of things another
another repository that's coming is API
repository and this is then a this will
be both a repository of free api's and
api is that we provide and also there'll
be a later an api marketplace for people
with private api's one of the things
that will be necessary there and is a
big piece of infrastructure that we're
building is an automated testing service
for api's so if you've created an api if
used you can get essentially an SLA with
us where if we accept your api we will
do automated testing on that api and if
there's going to be a problem with the
api in a future version of the cloud for
example we'll notify you before that
problem exists and if necessary fix it
so okay another thing we're doing is I
told you this is long and complicated
but another thing we're doing is the
notebook archive so this is there are no
books that have existed going back to
1988 and they mostly still work one
thing we're trying to do here is to make
a notebook archive for the ages so to
speak this will be part of our
foundation and the idea is that if you
have a notebook sort of that's for the
public good you can submit it to the
notebook archive and if it's accepted we
will try and keep it running forever and
it will be something that will be on the
web interactive as a computational thing
running inside the notebook archive
we're still in early stages of this and
still some issues being worked out here
but we are this this will be the the
notebook archive is is using this sort
of note book publishing mechanism here
and the I hope that they'll be um this
will probably be integrated with the
working language foundation that I
mentioned to you earlier that sort of is
maintaining the vitality of the wulfing
language itself we hope there'll be lots
of computational essays and the note
book archive we hope to do a kind of
expositions project where we try and get
computational essays pretty
just about everything just like their
Wikipedia pages about lots of things
which are kind of narrative descriptions
of things we want to create
computational expositions of things that
our thing our computational essays where
you can not only read the text but also
take the code and run it for your own
purposes and read the computational
language as a way to understand in
detail what's what's going on
and I hope some people here will get
involved in the expositions project like
Wikipedia it will be something where
people get to sign their exposition and
be the first person and to write the
exposition of something big and
important and people will read it for a
long time to come
one thing that we're doing is to try to
use our knowledge of repository making
to have a mechanism what on earth is
that that's what I expected um to have a
mechanism for sort of automatically copy
editing in effect computational essays
and that's something that will be coming
where you write a computational I say
and there's certain style guidelines
that we think you should follow and when
you submit it it will automatically make
suggestions to help you follow those
style guidelines I think there will be a
convenient way to do this um as I say we
we I think a big opportunity around note
book archive is the creation of
computational journals on top of it
we've got all sorts of amazing
capabilities now for creating and
publishing content for example courses
one thing we've been starting to work on
it's kind of integrated course authoring
tools which will be packaging up we've
created an for example in the
computer-based math initiative we've
created some really nice course
authoring systems but these will be
packaged up along with other things to
make sort of an integrated course
authoring tool system we have lots of
course content that we've been
delivering in okay so that's some we've
been lots of them lots of content in
will from you lots of course
lots of interactive courses deployed and
well from cloud like the version of my
elementary introduction book and so on
along with a data science course there's
now also a calculus course that exists
in Wolfe mu there's be an image
processing course that will be live next
week and we have a bunch of other
courses coming we have a linear algebra
course coming we have a neural networks
course coming we also have a course
about blockchains it's kind of I think
the clearest way to interact with
blockchains and they're complicated
things to interact with it's true of
language and notebooks and we have a
course based on that that's also kind of
a modern view of economics and the sort
of theory of money and so on we also
have an introduction to mathematical for
students and teachers that some that's
coming as another interactive MOOC um we
want to get other courses developed
really about subjects rather than about
how to do subject with Wolfram language
these are just subjects where Wolfram
language is part of the expositional
infrastructure not kind of the main
event so it's about X rather than X with
Wolfram language and if you're
interested in developing a course in
this framework please talk to us we we
are hoping to eventually have a large
collection of courses that can be
deployed through the network of site
licenses that we have and so on at in
educational organizations
well talking of education lots of we've
been doing new things there as well we
have oh there's the multi-paradigm data
science some okay we have we have these
various courses okay that's the
introduction image processing costs that
is interactive in the cloud there's the
video there's some there's the the text
and so on
oh that's that's the calculus course for
what it's worth
all right so how do I actually make sure
actually go to the course okay and I
should be able to show you the calculus
course I hope there we go
there it is um and okay so a new thing
sort of a new in-person course as our
data science bootcamp that we ran for
the first time this summer we'll be
running more of these this is a kind of
a quick way to get up to speed with data
science in Wolfram language and so
that's that's another educational
initiative and we've been continuing so
this year was I think the was at the
17th or 18th 17th summer school that we
had and it's always fun to check out the
projects that are done at our summer
school lots of lots of cool things that
get done in a three-week period
sort of original projects with Wolfram
language we also had our seventh high
school summer camp going that's a
two-week going from kind of zero to to
being able to do non-trivial projects
with often language on both the summer
school and the summer camp we are
increasing we are continuing our efforts
to kind of franchise these these
educational programs and people who are
interested in in that should should talk
to us on something that sort of spun out
of the stomach campus our well from an
emerging Leaders program I realized
somebody told me today that that the
acronym is whelp which turns out to be a
young wolf apparently I didn't know that
I should have known that um but that's
groups of summer camp students working
together after the summer camp so well
there's lots of opportunities to teach
computational thinking with our
technology stack at sort of all levels I
mean I wrote this one book um that has
been pretty useful for that I personally
have had a hobby for the last quite a
few years of teaching this stuff
middle school kids and I'm actually soon
going to it's kind of an interesting
contrast between what I do is a software
company CEO and and interacting with
middle school kids using our technology
um but actually one of the things I'm
doing is there's going to be on my
website collected demos of SW so to
speak with a bunch of the things that
I've done not only middle school kids
but also with other with other people I
think perhaps useful seeds for other
kinds of things people can do and
there's also going to be a variety of
other course materials made available
for doing things with computational
thinking in the Wolfram language uh
talking of bucks
well well from media has been publishing
some books just what was it two weeks
ago or last week the this book of mine
that's kind of a collection of the of
the none of the above blog posts that
I've written over the last little while
kind of things I've done sort of for fun
over the last several years being
described and there are a variety of
other more serious books that will be
coming out from wolf media in the in the
near future we're packaging the tools
that were used to make the eiw LV at the
elementary introduction book so that
other people can create books like that
I think it's a good format it's very
convenient format for for writing things
well so a lot of other opportunities to
publish orphan language related material
another another example of that is the
orphan community which has continued to
grow very successfully and by the way
one new thing in the Wolfram community
is embedding of notebooks finally
indirectly in community posts so this is
this is a new thing and it will get
progressively more more as that active
there no not yet it is active it will
become active oh there we go look at
this active cool um okay
and that's again using the notebook
publishing whoops that's using the
notebook publishing capability together
with the notebook wolfram notebook and
better in the community okay well I know
I've been going on a really really long
time but I wanted to gosh should I show
you some new stuff that's coming okay
okay okay there all right this is new
stuff I'm going to show you new stuff in
version 12.1 we're gonna be freezing the
code base for version 12.1 fairly soon
after this conference depending on how
long it takes to test it should be out
in the next few months so what's
happened in version 12.1 well there'll
be a lot of functions some of them will
be tagged as experimental initially we'd
like to know actually as I talked about
some of the things we're doing both into
our point one and beyond we'd like to
know what things you care most about
because that helps us set priorities
okay a long requested kind of basic
thing that's coming is high DPI for
Windows it's kind of like we finally we
did the sort of an infrastructure build
out to get 64-bit capabilities for the
Mac for version 12.04 Windows so
everything will look beautiful and sharp
in 12.1 okay we're doing a lot of stuff
to do with explaining things a lot of
cross-linking so we have these workflows
which are a new form of documentation
that we introduced I guess in 1200 and
there's a lot of kind of cross-linking
of documentation between workflows and
other things that's important for sort
of discoverability of how to do things
okay I mentioned the compiler a lot of
work is going on in the compiler very
large scale project kind of the test for
the compiler as as a large-scale project
is the compiler being able to compile
itself and we expect that to happen
fairly soon and that's important because
that will allow the compiler to get much
more efficient the first thing that will
happen is in terms of people's use of
the compiler is you've got a function
definition you've got a big lump of code
it will compile what it can compile
it might take a little while to do it
it'll be figuring out all sorts of
optimizations
but then that code will run blindingly
fast um it might have to call back into
the the main uncompelled kernel for
things that the compiler doesn't yet
know how to deal with or we'll never
know how to deal with later on they'll
be just-in-time compilation that will
become more and more common we've been
doing just some just-in-time compilation
for 30 years but this will be a much
richer okay but the other thing you can
expect from the compiler is all kinds of
spin-offs just like when we built the
cloud
there were spin-offs like the the
possibility of instant api's which
really doesn't need the whole cloud
infrastructure but it's something that
is sort of made possible by the
existence of that so here's a spin-off
that's new things coming in and she'll
be coming in 12.1 this is raw data
structures in Wolfram language so you'll
be able to do I mean you know a lot of
the time you don't need to know about
these low-level data structures but when
you're writing really optimized code you
might want a linked list for example
something that is genuinely definitively
a linked list so here I just created a
linked list and I can say give me
information about that it'll say it's a
linked list with no entries it'll tell
me there's certain operations I can do
on the linked list like appending to it
so here I might do let's say append just
do append to the linked list 100 random
integers so now I asked for information
about the linked list it'll have ten
entries if I say get me the the pure
expression version of the linked list
there it is just as an ordinary list but
I could say just show me a visualization
of the linked list there it is with
little links in between and so that's
but now we can take that linked list
that that intrinsic linked list oh I
should explain what this has to do with
a compiler what this has to do with the
compiler is that all the code that deals
with a linked list is simply written in
top-level orphan language code and
compiled by the compiler so this is it's
completely open code that you can look
at and then it's compiled to low-level
machine code by the compiler and so you
know if I want to add a million things
to a linked list incrementally it takes
point six seven seconds um and so that's
that's that's pretty neat and you can
then in
to integrate this with other compiled
code because the data types that the
compiler knows about will include all of
these derived data types that are part
of the data structures project so it's
efficient for writing particular kinds
of programs if you understand these
kinds of low-level data structures you
can now use them also for computer
science education it's really pretty
neat because things will actually you
know run at the you you can actually
directly work with these kinds of data
structures if you have ideas for more
data structures please let us know we're
probably they'll be about 30 common data
structures in the initial version ok
another thing that's coming is a new
package format and that's sort of linked
in with a package repository but it's
something that will exist independently
a kind of symbolic representation of
packages something that's in 12.1 is
faster integration with things like
pythons about four times faster also a
bunch of new languages available in
external evaluate so for example you
will be able to do that see if this
works I can start an external session
and Julia and I can then run julia code
from inside Wolfram language and there
will also be let's see Ruby our TCL and
possibly Haskell and Go available in
version 12.1 and I mean you can you can
kind of open this and under the hood
it's kind of complicated what's going on
but from the point of view of the user
it should be fairly easy um
not our responsibility if you have all
kinds of tangled libraries running in
these external languages not not for us
that's some if you don't want tangled
libraries use Wolfram language um yeah
um
so okay let's look at some other things
here so another thing that's coming see
I'm I'm I'm doing all kinds of fancy
footwork here because I am now going to
run a prototype build let me see
um this is kind of demo art I suppose um
so this is data set um data set is going
to have a bunch of new things in version
12.1 so for example if I right click on
this I can say sort that column and so
that's uh so data set is becoming the
display of data set is becoming much
more sophisticated and you can do
operations
directly in the GUI for data set you can
also the or another thing with data set
actually it's not visible here is and
you'll be seeing this in a lot of
functions it's the save in notebook
capability so when there's something
with a lot of data in one of these
things there's a question of whether you
actually want to save all that data on
the notebook whether you want to refer
to an external resource potentially an
external resource in the cloud or an
external or local external resource so
if you put it all in the notebook it'll
all be there and anybody else who opens
that notebook will be able to get it the
bad news is it might be really big and
it might make your notebook 200
megabytes or something you can also say
I just want to store it locally on my
machine so you'll be able to use it
anytime you want but other people won't
or you can say it push it to the cloud
and make its public in the cloud and
then other people can access it as well
so that's that's that kind of mechanism
another thing that is coming here is
table view and let's see if I can show
you that um and let's just make a so
table view is a kind of spreadsheet view
and we can go and just type in you know
foo and we can just just use this just
like a standard spreadsheet like thing
and we can we can do we can sort columns
and things if we evaluate this we'll get
back essentially a normal expression
there if we say normal of that we'll
just get the normal expression so this
is just a convenient way of doing sort
of tabular data entry in the language
okay why I had this next but I had
another example it's just an utterly
different area I can't imagine how this
is connected but why on earth do I have
this here this is a horse anatomy I
don't know why we
horse Anatomy in all of this just just a
lot of new things that are coming in in
addition to horse did Anatomy um this is
historical countries which are a whole
represent a whole nother framework for
um for dealing with dealing with geo
data another thing I don't know why
that's taking so long
I guess it's doing it's computing
something about military conflicts in
World War two okay well let it run um
okay while it's doing that let's look at
something else over here
another thing that's coming is oh there
we go
that's a heat map of casualties and and
where casualties occurred in battles in
World War two it's kind of interesting
actually um it's um okay it's
interesting all right um okay this is
another thing that's coming and that
didn't work um that would work okay that
is something that's coming is some bio
sequences so we've had symbolic
representation of molecules we're also
having symbolic representation of
genomic sequences protein sequences and
so on and being able to do computations
with those wonder whether this work
let's try this one here
I don't spinning its spinning its
spinning I don't know what it's gonna do
oh okay
did something okay so there are two bio
sequences and now we're going to do
sequence alignment between those two bio
sequences and that didn't work properly
but any case that that's some so that's
another thing is support for bio
sequences um okay
completely different area here is
well okay let me show you this um is
we've had drawing tools for a long time
but I think the UI has been kind of
crummy this is now I hope a good UI for
drawing tools so here you've got to
you've got some tools here it says draw
a polyline that's that's draws some line
chunk chunk chunk um okay and now we
have um let's click there okay so when
we've clicked there um we get up I think
get up
there we go and now we get the ability
to just a nice UI for doing this we get
the ability to change that polyline
change its opacity etcetera etcetera
etcetera there's just - just a nice user
interface for drawing tools and now you
can you can have that go there okay
so um let's go back something else this
is about quantum computing
so we've people have used often language
and Mathematica for quantum computing
for a long time we okay we've um oh I
was going to show you one more thing
with with molecules this is just like
you can do text recognition you can also
do molecule recognizer and so this will
take a image of a drawing of a molecule
and it should if all is correct actually
recognize that molecule okay
so this is a way of taking you know
doing OCR of molecules basically um and
okay having talked about that it's a
good segue to quantum computing so what
we're trying to do is to make kind of a
uniform framework for doing quantum
computing or doing sort of discrete
state quantum mechanics as a quantum
discrete state we can say what are the
amplitudes in that quantum discreet
state will get some result with various
ket's there we can say apply a quantum
discreet operator like a c not operator
to the quantum tensor product of that
state with itself and now we can do a
quantum measurement there's a quantum
measurement and what do you get out of a
quantum measurement we get a data
distribution and we can do with that
data distribution we can for example
work out what's the mean of that data
distribution so this is the moment where
we go from the quantum with the
symbolically represented quantum thing
to the classical data distribution okay
so let's see other kinds of things we
are doing a lot of infrastructure stuff
about supporting non planes or a unicode
emojis supporting library link in the
front
and which turns out is important for
things like video updating rendering
technologies we're going to have a
standard notebook toolbar you can do
things like come add a background to a
notebook okay there we go there's a
background for our notebook um and this
is some some we can better reset there's
notebook if I can see to do it there we
go okay we reset it good
um the we're also other kinds of things
that we're doing the notion of form
notebooks being able to have a notebook
which is kind of a a notebook that acts
like a form where you kind of fill it
out a little bit like the way that you
enter things for the function repository
but now there's kind of a notebook where
you're putting in content and then that
content can be deployed as an expression
and so on um different area databases
user databases in the cloud writable
databases that's what we're working
towards and 12.1 there'll be additional
support for readable databases all sorts
of new embedded SQL strings things like
that also enhancing support for MongoDB
and working towards support for things
like spark
I'll show you one one other thing here
this is some in supporting graph stores
and that's a bad sign but let's see
whether things work anyway okay so one
thing we can do is use wiki data and so
for example we can search in wiki data
for things that match extremely large
telescopes so there are two wiki data ID
objects that match the the phrase
extremely large telescope and we can now
use wiki data data to go and use use
Sparkle and so on under the hood to go
and find properties of that from within
wiki data so this will now use wiki data
to get this case apparently a rather
small thumbnail of a picture of the
extremely large telescope and we can go
ahead and say we can do all kinds of
things we can ask wiki data you know
some question about aspirin and it will
go and use sparkle to query rookie data
I don't you know
we're not responsible for the quality of
stuff that's in wiki data but this is a
convenient way to get access to it
another thing that's coming is the
general use of external identifies like
there are a variety of kinds of IDs for
things in the world like ISP ends for
books this is a way to have general
access symbolic access to those external
identifiers okay another thing is some
external storage so this is a uniform
interface to external storage systems
that see if this works
oh it didn't work okay I'm the oil here
let's just do something trivial here
let's just say hello here see if that
works so this will there we go okay so
we just permanently stored the string
hello in the IP FS distributed
blockchain like storage system out in
the world you'll also be able to do this
probably more interestingly with things
like s3 and other external storage
systems also coming is the ability to
run jobs in cloud service services like
AWS we ourselves have been doing machine
learning in AWS for a long time we're
going to be packaging that up for people
to use lots more stuff with neural nets
particularly as a result of supporting
the onyx standard for neural net
interchange we'll be able to deal with
for example tensor flow models better
we'll be able to have standalone neural
nets we've been working a lot for
version 12.1 on reinforcement learning
and there'll be some and gans and
there'll be some things with that too
new super functions to do with speech
interpreter as an example of that lots
of infrastructure stuff
managing external processes kernel
connection manager dealing with the
system keychain for remembering
passwords and so on a convenient way to
to deal with external services so you
don't have to kind of write down your
passwords or burn them into your code
you can include that in a system
keychain we also have a new channel
broker system based on mqtt let me show
you one example here
um in that I should be able to do and um
if I can do this
this is notebooks streaming this is a
new thing made possible with the channel
framework so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to create a streaming notebook and
they say create notebook stream there's
gonna be a streaming notebook and I
could type them two plus two nothing you
won't see anything here but now if I go
here and I say connect to the notebook
stream so I say view existing stream
this is called foo and I say view
existing stream and I put that over here
and now when I type let's say 100
factorial here look at that you'll see
it coming out on that external so so
what you can do is I could be streaming
from this notebook and any of you could
be getting that notebook stream to you
and so for example I I should have a an
accomplice in the audience here and
let's see whether I can can connect to
another stream here I let's see we
should have another stream that is
called let's see whether this works
pilot's notebook streaming ok so we saw
a Jesse F at wilton.com :
Jesse Stream and then we'll save you
existing stream and now we should see a
stream if this works correctly
connecting the stream ok it's still
trying let's see what's happening here
well maybe I don't see my accomplice in
the audience which is a bad sign my
accomplice may have gone home hi well so
much for that that would have been cool
if it had worked
um the okay what you should be able to
see is and I think it will be useful for
some educational applications and so on
is Ustream anybody in the audience can
be picking up that stream sort of
character by character in real time and
so case you're wondering we are we're
working on sort of full collaborative
editing in the cloud and so on but
something works on the desktop this is
something where you're getting streaming
of content into the desktop okay more
stuff infrastructure service connect
frame worth both to support again these
things sound kind of boring
infrastructural but they're really
important for a lot of actual
applications support for sam'l and
Shibboleth LTI and LMS integration
that's very important for a bunch of
educational organizations for example
various kinds of external authentication
from social media and so on in
enterprise private clouds using key
cloak to do authentication I should say
internally just you know one of the
things we're doing is a where we have a
variety of big projects you can see some
of them happening on live streams we
have some core language development we
have a thing we call LCC language
completeness and consistency which is
something we're sort of continuously
trying to improve also we have a LD
incremental language development we're
planning all sorts of all sorts of
enhancements to the language for example
in areas like exception handling another
project we've just recently kicked off
is what we call IQD incremental quality
development which is basically we've got
lots of long-standing very low priority
bugs we're going to try and fix lots of
them um and that okay good that's good
okay so that was a that was a vote of
the its some okay so we're using our
system internally a lot one of the big
things we're building as an ERP system
we've had big crunch ERP systems in our
company for a long time sort of fed up
with those we want to build a sign II
new symbolic ERP system and it's going
really really well and it's a really
interesting thing it's a really
interesting use of our technology
another area is boy III I told you this
has got crazy right I mean there's just
we're doing a lot of stuff in case you
haven't noticed I'm the another area is
code assistants and so what we've been
interested in there is
um well okay so here for example if I
here's something that's new if I say Li
now so much for that I think I have to
enable code enable this hold on a second
um yeah there we go
this is just a temporary thing unable
that and now we can say if I say Li P
will see that will autocomplete to list
plot so it's just a we're just enhancing
our ability to do what our completion
just a useful thing they'll save you
know seconds two minutes per day for
people so another area is some this may
or may not work here I don't think this
is gonna work um okay this is not gonna
work this is some something that we've
been working on is code advisories so
just like you have spell checking and
you have little squiggly red lines
underneath words that might be spelled
wrong so we're going to have squiggly
lines underneath code that we think is
wrong and that means and sometimes it'll
actually be correct just like sometimes
you really meant to spell the word that
way but often it won't be and so the
idea will be that that's we're
identifying this both using rules I'm
using machine learning methods and
there'll be suggestions about how to
make the code right and there's pretty
interesting user interface around this
same kind of thing when you have a
syntax error and you have mismatched
brackets for example there's going to be
something using machine learning which
can predict where the likely place where
you should add a bracket actually is
okay
so other things to mention lots of stuff
with block trained we have a block chain
Oracle sort of Oracle for computational
facts that's coming we have an
implementation of virtual machines like
if you're in virtual machine things to
do with has so much stuff I the we now
have with text cases this natural
language processing capability that's
pretty powerful there's sort of this
loop between natural language
understanding and natural language
process
saying they have a Wikipedia article it
mentions countries
it mentions some historical country that
we've never heard of but yet our natural
language processing machine learning
system can say that's probably a country
and now we're doing this kind of quality
assurance loop going between our and LP
capabilities and our and all you
capabilities to improve both of them um
ok other kinds of things we have we have
some things in see web here's an example
web geometry search this is now
searching the web for geometry um so
let's say I asked it to search for
teacups and it got me that tea cup I can
now copy that tea cup I hope I'm copy
and paste the tea cup okay so now I can
do something like I can say I'm get me
the resource data of that and I should
have a tea cup here there we go I have a
tea cup um and that just came from just
some random website and now I can say
take that and okay didn't work or maybe
it did work this is a this is using
shaders GPU maybe my machine doesn't
have a GPU but anyway this is using GPU
based shaders to do things other things
that are happening there for example
this is a cross hatching being put in
graphics lots of things around that okay
well lots and lots of other stuff we've
got some things about resolution theorem
proving we've got we can finally do all
those syllogisms like come let's go back
yeah we can say things like come some
example here
and that really didn't work okay let's
try the help okay there we go so there's
there's a little syllogism and we can
then prove that syllogism and we can
look at the proof of that and so on um
okay well lots of other kinds of things
things with proof assistants like lien
and so on another completely different
area is block based interfaces too often
language is just a prototype of being
able to click together blocks to do well
from language programming and then
running the thing in the cloud yet
another thing that's coming we've got
some C system server's project of sort
of privatizing all the different pieces
of our infrastructure we've just
installed some new geo servers which
will allow us to do new things with geo
computation okay so lots and lots of
different stuff another thing that's
coming that's a consequence of a bunch
of low-level infrastructure is the
ability to handle video and so let me
let me see what I can pull in a piece of
video here um and this will just be in a
notebook let's see if this works okay
let's see what's gonna happen here okay
so hopefully hopefully hopefully this is
a video play there we go yeah this is a
video player write in a notebook um and
now we can actually do things with this
video so let's say we take as a function
video map and so let's take that video
and let's make image measurements on
that video so we're going to map we're
going to find the mean intensity of each
color in every frame of that video and
that will give us a see here's a plot
for that video processing that video
directly of the RGB values for
successive frames in the video so lots
of things there okay so that was a
little bit on what's coming in version
12.1 and beyond um we certainly will be
describing something we're doing sort of
for the community is a thing called
Wolfram sightings with a see page of
things that people have done with all of
this although
the stuff that we've built that's
something that's coming I personally
been doing a fair amount of stuff in the
last year you can kind of follow what
I've been doing on my Twitter feed um
and the I might mention oh gosh so many
different things I've been been doing a
fair amount of historical work for
example trying to figure out what the
real origin of our favorite spiky is you
can read about that and it ends
somewhere in Brazil with some things
called Gilman those um but another thing
another project we've been doing is some
a project to do with history of math for
the National Museum of mathematics which
I've been involved with since it since
it started it's based based in Manhattan
and we've been working on building a
history of math working on sort of the
infrastructure for a history of math
Gallery and so for example here's a
there's a little thing that got done
let's see what I can run this oh well
that didn't work well um the this is
just um manipulate that shows well
hopefully it will show all the different
number systems that have been used in
history and kind of shows there um how
numbers are represented in those
different number systems and now that
now the real challenge is to find actual
artifacts that illustrate numbers being
used in all these different kinds of
number systems and we've been working
hard on that so um the okay so other
things that um well I've written all
kinds of wild and wild blog posts and
things about some all sorts of different
strange stuff um the you see the thing
that um well another great example of
our technology that that I think come
has been
ah you see if I can show you I've been
interested I I'm a kind of a big
collector that did not work I'm a big
collector of
and work either okay so a thing we've
been doing I've been a pretty good
archivist at my own material and so I
have like quarter million pages of
scanned documents and things and I also
have done a fair amount of historical
research so I've interacted with lots of
archivists and one of the things that
happens we talk what I talk to
archivists is they say boy if you guys
ever build a system for doing archiving
we'd be thrilled because there aren't
really good systems for for managing
archives and so on so I have this big
personal archive of my own which I
intend to start exposing in the next few
years and so we decide we're gonna build
an archiving system actually it's really
neat because by using resource system
and by using kind of symbolic
representation of archive material once
able to do a lot of things by having
machine learning tools and so on one can
one can do even more things it's really
really a cool tool set up um you know
I've been personally much involved in
trying to sort of understand what what
it means for for a sort of AI to run the
world and so on and how that maps into
things to do with computational
contracts you know one of the things
with Wharf languages we have a language
for expressing things computationally
including expressing things like legal
contracts which are normally written in
legalese but now we can imagine writing
them in sort of precise computational
language that's kind of a an interesting
story I gotten involved in a few things
related to that like for example I got
roped into testifying and the Senate
about um the problem of it's basically I
I view it as kind of one of the the
first skirmishes in the AI war so to
speak and what it's about is a lot of
systems you know Facebook Google Twitter
whatever do automated content selection
they use an AI to decide how they should
rank content for your news feed or your
search results or whatever else and
people are upset because they say that
AI isn't doing what I want that AI to do
and people then say well well okay
somebody's got to set up what are the
ethics of that AI what's that what is it
what's that AIS value system what kind
of content should have ban what kind of
content should have promote
and so I was first thinking about kind
of okay that's sort of it was a proposal
to let's just open up these AIS and just
check that they aren't doing anything
bad that's a really doomed idea both
practically and even theoretically one
one thinks about computational
irreducibility than all these kinds of
things you just can't tell what the AI
is thinking so to speak because it
doesn't think the way we think and
there's sort of fundamental limitations
that if you really want to use
computation you end up with irreducible
computation so okay so having realized
that that wasn't going to work I started
thinking about well how could you do
this and I figured out this whole scheme
that involves these things third party
ranking providers and so on basically
making use of the idea that people kind
of identify if they say I want my
content provided by some knowin entity
or brand well that entity has some known
values some knowin sort of you know it's
that it's a media company or it's
some-some I don't know religious
organization whatever else it has some
knowin values that people associate with
that brand and effect so then the
technical problem becomes how do you
bottle up those values what do you how
do you represent that system of values
and what you realize is you have to kind
of build an AI that represents that
system of values and this is something
that with our kind of computational
language with our ability to express
computational ideas we have sort of the
unique opportunity to do this to build
kind of the AI that represents the value
system of of some some organization for
example that can then be plugged in to
actually be the thing that does the
final ranking of concept so that's
another another activity
I've been oh gosh so many things I mean
I've been another thing you might have
seen recently is something well actually
I've been I have various writing
projects i'm i've been i've been toying
with writing a book that is sort of an
introduction to modern computation that
tries to do as I've said there's sort of
the what you need to know about
computation to do computational X and
it's not learning low-level programming
and it's kind of well what should you
and the elementary introduction wolfmann
language provides some of that but I
think I'm going to do something which
has a slightly more general sort of a
general thing that can be used as a sort
of general college costs about about
computation and so on but anyway I've
been I've been going back doing some
science this is a this is a thing that
I've long wanted to do my favorite rule
30 cellular automaton which is this very
simple rule very complicated behavior
there are these questions about it that
I've been sort of wondering about for
about 40 years
I've now put up these prizes in the
hopes that having not figured them out
myself I'll be able to get other people
to figure them out that worked really
successfully in 2007 with finding the
proving the the simplest universal
Turing machine okay so the final thing
that I'm really excited about actually
myself right now is some is something
quite different I as some of you will
know I I kind of started my life doing
physics and I've been interested in
physics ever since and I having explored
the computational universe I kind of got
what when I did physics I didn't really
think I just was doing physics as
physics was presented at the time using
sort of the standard paradigms of things
like general activity in quantum field
theory and but later on when I really
studied the computational universe and
studied all these simple programs and
all the funky things they do I started
thinking about what um what the whether
there's potentially a way the surprise
is that in this computational universe
even very simple programs do very
complicated things so that makes for
wonder is there a different
infrastructure for physics than the one
that's been used so far and the one
we've had we've got now of quantum field
theory general sylheti about a hundred
years old and it's had a pretty good run
but it certainly hasn't finished the job
of finding sort of a fundamental theory
of physics so I've been interested for a
long time and maybe one could actually
really do that and actually recently
made some progress in in sort of
clarifying the model and now we're
actually I'm about to launch a serious
project to try and find the fundamental
theory of physics and we've been
assembling a
great team I think to try and do that
and you know the ideas we have might be
might be the wrong idea might be the
wrong century to try and do it but
something I want to do and I want to
make it something that the world can
kind of be part of and so we're going to
kind of livestream the search for the
fundamental theory of physics and you
can probably got a few examples here of
just sort of the it's kind of
interesting that that what's possible
now is so much more powerful as the
result of the tools that we have today
than it ever was before I mean if I if I
just go and look at um oh I don't know
let's see this is just current working
material but but ton see what they've
got here let's say this um I'm not going
to that's age not list example let's see
I want a different example
oh come on where did that go I'm the I'm
not I'm about done so um so that's the
I'm not going to explain this here
that's a hyper graph that is relevant to
sort of understanding the structure of
space-time um but you know what what's
fun about this is in the end these are a
bunch of functions in the function
repository and things that were building
with all the latest technology and so on
and it's really a very different picture
of what physics some of what it means to
kind of explore fundamental physics and
actually I have to say just in the last
few weeks I become exceptionally
optimistic about about this approach and
about what's what's possible with it um
and you know there are there are fun
things you'll see there are all kinds of
things with repositories of candidate
universes and all sorts of fun things
that will be coming once we get this
project really launched in the in the
public view ok well so we'll see what
happens with physics but whatever
happens with physics I think it's fair
to say that kind of the computational
paradigm is already very firmly
established we've worked for a long time
to kind of realize the potential of that
paradigm and to sort of build the
computational and language that enables
all these computational acts and I have
to say you know I think it's sort of a
historic time now you know whenever one
is in the middle of a historic time one
can't tell that it's a historic time but
from sort of my knowledge of kind of
history of science and milestone my own
personal experience of how these things
work this is a historic time this is a
time when the tools exist to really
launch computational X for all X and
it's going to happen and it's going to
happen probably quite quickly different
at different times for different X's and
it's something something really exciting
that's going on and I'm I'm pleased that
we've been able over the last thirty
years or so to build the tools that I
think are going to make this possible
and it's I'm really looking forward to
seeing what happens and I should say
well thank you to people here and in
this community for being with us on this
journey and please help us to bring
along more of the world on this journey
and for now please enjoy the conference
thanks very much
[Applause]